almost everything about this clothing is
organic
every fiber and even the buttons are
biodegradable and leave behind no toxic
residue
the garments come from the zurich
workshop of the brothers daniel and
marcus freitag
their first line of sustainable clothes
is called fabric
do we make fashion we make fabric and
create
fashion from it it seems collider we
wanted to have work clothes that are
consistent with our principles
and they're not so easy to find so
we decided to make it ourselves
they hunted for biodegradable fabrics
from environmentally friendly producers
and came up
empty-handed so they developed fabrics
themselves
from bass hemp and flax after five years
they'd done it
complete with a patented solution for
trouser buttons
natural fibers are biodegradable as long
as they haven't been in contact with too
many or the wrong chemicals
in our case everything from the thread
to the buttons are compostable
but the buttons are metal so we came up
with another strategy
these can be unscrewed and reused on the
next pair of trousers
the frytogs came to fame in 1993 with a
recycling concept
they began making bags out of old tarps
from trucks every component had a
previous life
the bags quickly found buyers around the
world today there are 40 models
the success inspired the brothers from
zurich to continue their sustainable
production principle
instead of upcycling they went into
cradle to cradle fashions
all the materials are part of a
never-ending cycle modeled after nature
itself pi talk is about cycles we
breathe new life into old trucks and
produce
bags from parts of them this atmosphere
this cyclical thinking is central to the
concept
fully biodegradable fashion is nothing
new one of the pioneers was the german
textile company tregema their organic
cotton products carry the cradle to
cradle certificate
all the raw materials used can
theoretically become nutrients again
the puma sporting goods label shifted
into biodegradable materials in 2013.
trend researcher karen frick says
collections like these are trailblazers
in future we'll be wearing more
environmentally friendly garments
clothing that has been produced
sustainably according to
fair trade principles but the clothes
won't look like they were produced that
way
right now these eco trousers are an
environmental statement
and not a fashion statement
the frytog brothers want to unite
sustainable and stylish
they ambitiously follow a holistic
approach
with production only in europe hemp and
flax are grown in normandy in france
the fibers are spun into thread in italy
and then woven into fabrics there as
well
finally the garments are stitched
together in poland
all the steps take place within a 2 500
kilometer radius of zurich
the brothers have made an advertising
film to promote their credo of making
fashion fair
and sustainable club clever smart
advertising is really decisive for
environmentally friendly fashion you
need to reach the masses
sustainable underwear has been available
for years in supermarkets but it's not
stylish
style needs a special cool moment
and a good story this t-shirt returns to
the soil
and could provide the organic matter to
grow another hemp plant one day
this one was composted for two months
even the tagawa knot buttons broke down
and after six months even the trousers
decayed
it's become clear to us that what
happens during composting troubles
people
they're worried their clothes will break
down in the wash
it's important to explain that lots of
small insects and climatic conditions
are required for the t-shirts to
decompose
the brothers are selling their new line
in their zurich shop
they're still making just t-shirts
trousers and pinafores in three
different colors
the prices range from 70 to 200 euros
and they want to give consumers more to
choose from
in the future it'll be the raw material
for any type of creation
we've decided to follow a direction in
which we're not aiming at just one
little niche
organisation
they started small with bags way back
when
now they want to build on their success
with garments that can be thrown onto
the compost heap
with a clear conscience when their time
is up